hello I'm Emily anguin in our Doha
headquarters these are the top stories
on Al Jazeera we begin with breaking
news out of Ukraine the mayor of Kiev
has confirmed there have been several
large explosions in the center of the
city let's bring in Rory challenge who's
in the Ukrainian Capital Rory what more
can you tell us
hi Emily these were multiple strikes
that took place not very long ago at the
most half an hour ago the damage the
casualties are still being assessed at
the moment but uh
some time ago there were a number of
loud explosions around the city it seems
that the a downtown area called
chefchenko was hit Vitale Klitschko
who's the mayor of Kiev has said that
that's the area that some of the
explosions took place in uh that is a
university area it's where government
buildings are I've just seen a video on
social media showing burning cars uh no
bodies I've seen yet but it looks as if
there are certainly uh casualties
um the uh there were other areas so
other cities in Kiev in Ukraine that
have been hit uh overnight and this
morning we know of strikes on the knee
Pro and we know of strikes on zaparisia
which has been hit multiple times over
the last few days now ukrainians are in
no doubt that the this uptick in missile
strikes is retaliation from Vladimir
Putin for that strike on the Kirch
bridge in in Crimea just a day or two
ago
Kiev as a capital city has been pretty
unscathed by missile strikes for months
now a lot it's been a long time since
the last strikes here so much so that
when the air raid sirens go off these
days people barely bat an eyelid and
they go about their daily business I
think this will change that the city's
authorities are saying that there is
still a danger of more strikes and that
people should stay inside air raid
shelters and not go out onto the streets
all right Rory thank you very much for
the update and no doubt we'll cross back
to you throughout the day Rory challenge
live for us there in the capital Kiev